do you know something in the game of
life you're playing a cricket match
against an entity called the mind no one
on planet Earth can stop you from
accomplishing and achieving what you
want if you can bat against the Googlies
that the Mind bowls at you how many of
you have trouble in studying and you
come here you hear all of these things
don't get distracted by WhatsApp don't
get distracted by internet pornography
don't get distracted by Twitter study
how many of you wanted to wake up early
in the morning results and how many of
you have done something called as
setting an alarm clock and then after
setting the alarm clock whether you want
it or not it rings and when it rings the
Mind puts its first googly what does the
Mind do by putting the googly when you
do the first snooze you are out if you
snooze you are out hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I struggle
to believe in myself I quit on my
business partner and the thing that
saved me was watching the successful
stories of entrepreneurs they gave me
the inspiration to keep going as well as
the strategies of what to do and quite
honestly I still need their stories and
motivation today as well so today let's
live your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only your gopal Das
I want to say one thing just one and
probably this will change the direction
of your life you know something when you
snooze the alarm
what happens
you decide to give in to the mind's ball
and this is how your morning Begins by
giving into the mind is
[Music]
giving
and it's no problem giving in sleeping
five minutes extra is no problem the
problem is you develop the attitude of
giving in
you tell yourself that what I decided
last night is not as important what is
important is what the mind says because
we listen I'll tell you something my
humble advice
because it's not just about getting up
in the morning it's about every aspect
of life whether it's your work if you're
working whether it's your study if
you're studying whatever we do
the problem is it's not about one thing
it reflects in every area of life
[Music]
don't allow that snooze there is a
concept called sledging in cricket where
the opponent team comes and gives Gali
to the breadsmen
Kali they try to distract them and take
their focus away
one thing that Sachin is adored for
in the history of cricket is sledging
hasn't bothered him
this man is cool
are you cool when people do sledging
against you in The Game of Life
are you cool
or you lose your cool there will always
be people who are out of control
can you stop a guy from criticizing you
can you start an opponent team from
sledging
it's called things which are out of our
control people are out of our control
sometimes our situations in your control
many times
the guy who was batting was expecting an
in-swing ball and that's what the boiler
bowled
and one gush of wind an in-swing becomes
an outswing and is caught out
a lot of things situations people are
just out of our control how many of you
think question paper is in your control
yeah
and when things go wild no I'll tell you
what happens with us
this is what happens with us
[Music]
this is what happens with us see
how it comes up
we react
the stimulus of
a person sledging against us criticizing
pulling us down envious of us conspiring
politicking
makes us react and form out right to
ever we start reacting also
and look at this this is also sealed
[Music]
the question is do you want to be a 7UP
can
or a oxicle bottle of water
and I'm sure a lot of us would say
um
and thus in our life we will always have
a stimulus
and we can choose to respond because
between the stimulus and response is our
choice
[Music]
in the Maternity Ward
a great personality is born by the
choices that one makes
[Music]
and therefore when there are all kinds
of stimuli we have to learn how to
respond
if we are not strong spiritually it is
impossible
if we are not strong culturally it is
impossible all this sounds great and
good and we know yes but I want to do it
I can't be a can of soda I want to be a
water bottle but is it so easy
no
that is why coming here is so important
that is why this foundational ethics of
spirituality are so crucial in this age
as all of you
are going to be successful in your own
areas of life if not Cricket per se
and thus we have to learn how to respond
what is the most selfish
one-lettered word
I isn't it everything revolves around I
phone
iPad
iPod and the man says I paid
words around the eye
and what does I stand for I stands for
expectations I should be treated like
this I should be loved like this I
should be dealt with like this I should
be respected like this I should be given
these many marks I should not be given
this
you're all leading a life of super high
expectations everything revolves around
my opinions my desires my likes my
dislikes I love this I want this I don't
want this I I I I I I I
you think life will be a very happy life
when it revolves around I
from a childhood we have grown up like
this
we've only learned to take and everyone
has to fulfill my expectations
everything has to be up to my
expectations wherefore when people come
to God people come to Temple also they
only asking
give me what I want
no one comes to say I love you I want I
want to give you
when the president of the United States
John F Kennedy came up to a stage for
his first presidential speech
his voice rumbled into the public
address system when he said ask not
what the country can do for you
ask what you can do for the country and
so we are saying ask not what God can do
for you ask what you can do for God but
no one asks that because the eye is so
big my expectations my desires my things
are so powerful that even when I come to
a temple and ring a bell all I'm doing
is asking the more we lead a life of I
or I will always be frustrated
because people don't exist in this world
to just fulfill your expectations
therefore ladies and gentlemen
most selfish one-lettered word is I
which stands for
expectations and therefore avoid this
word
how do you avoid this word
be realistic in your expectations
but understand that not everyone will
fulfill your expectation
and secondly avoid this word I
by trying to serve others
you know why
because when you want to be served
you're dependent on people they may not
serve you
when you want to serve who can stop you
when you want respect people may not
respect you but when you want to give a
respect
who can stop you when you want to be
loved
you may not be loved but when you want
to give love who can stop you when you
want and charity people may not give you
in charity but when you want to give
charity who can stop you and therefore
learn
to begin your journey from I to you the
more you want for yourself you'll remain
frustrated the more you want to give
you will remain happy when you want to
achieve success in your career in your
academics in your pro business in your
profession we will fail and that's the
example of the giraffe
when the baby giraffe is born Falls from
such a high distance straight on the
ground
the mother positions herself right above
the baby giraffe
and guess what she does first gives it a
hard kick but okay
so much
so as it's just coming out of the impact
the mother gives a bad second harder
kick now the guy understands
foreign
starts getting up on its wobbly legs you
know
on its wobbly legs and as the baby
giraffe gets up on the bobbly like
he gets up and starts running and then
the mother giraffe goes hugs the baby
and starts kissing the baby you know why
because the baby giraffe's flesh is very
soft and supple and hyenas and lions
love it the mother knows that I can't be
with the baby giraffe all the time to go
and get food for the baby
how would I protect it is
here
we fail we should get up and we'll fail
again we should get up and like I always
say Don't just go through life grow
through life also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
what's quite amazing isn't it that when
something stuck in our tooth
the tongue just keeps going to that
tooth
until unless that stuff is out of our
tooth it just keeps going there
now this 31 other teeth in our mouth
when nothing stuck
the tongue can go there and say hey wow
look there's nothing stuck here go to
one of the other tooth where there's
nothing stuck and say hey look amazing
there's nothing stuck here
but just the nature of the tongue that
it keeps going to where something is
stuck
and surely
we have to deal with it whenever I
travel in my handbag I always have
dental floss and a box of toothpicks
with me just in case something is stuck
I have to take it out certainly we have
to deal with it
at the same time
there's a lot of other good things that
we can focus on
ladies and gentlemen
it's not just the nature of the tongue
isn't it the nature of the mind as well
when there is a problem an issue stuck
in a certain area of our life the Mind
keeps going
to that problem and just gets stuck into
the negativity of trying to deal with it
but there's 31 or shall I say many many
more
good things happening in so many
different areas of our life where
there's no problems no issues stuck
yet the mind only keeps going
to those areas there are problems
it is necessary therefore for all of us
that we focus
on the good that is happening in our
life
[Music]
with the bad or the problems that are
happening in our life
let us not consume our minds with
negativity
let us consume our minds with positivity
focus on the positive and deal with the
negative most often if not always Our
Lives seem to be out of balance
and when lives are out of balance it
makes us very irritable
you know when we drive a car we always
drive a car and a car has four wheels a
rhetorical thing to say isn't it you
drive a car
on these four wheels
and this four wheels in the car of Life
represent first wheel your personal life
your health your mind yourself the
things that you love to do the things
that you would want to do not have to do
most times we live a life of have to do
I have to study I have to work I have to
pay my bills I have to pay the taxes I
have to do this and I have to do that I
have to go for the social function I
don't have a choice I have to have to
have to have to where did the love to go
we just end up living a life of have
twos
and I've forgot about our own selves
by subscribing to the pressures that
come from all fronts in our lives we've
forgotten to live our own lives
we don't have time to unwind
we don't have time to spend with our own
selves we don't have time to be with
nature and take a deep breath and just
relish the crispness of the air
we don't have the time to do all of that
especially in a metropolitan City like
this
when the pressures are so high and the
pace is so fast we just don't have time
for ourselves ladies and gentlemen
and that's one car one wheel of our car
isn't it
personal life our health for instance
such an important thing
but at the cost of just running we
forget to pay attention to our own
health the second wheel of the car is
family life
demands attention isn't it your personal
life demands attention your family life
demands attention isn't it
before marriage when you are in love
they call it a crush isn't it but after
marriage all that is left is Candy Crush
all the crushes are and gone and all
that you're left with is a Candy Crush
just keep playing Candy Crush
laughs
and all the headaches coming from all
the pressures
one lady went to a doctor and the doctor
said how's your headache Madam she said
he's out of town
gosh I must tell you
this Demands a lot of attention your
personal life the first Tire do you have
one
do you have a personal life is my
question
do you have time for your health
even in my hectic schedule I have made
five days of exercises still
in all the lectures and all the talks
and everywhere I go because that's
what's going to keep me going
I have to give time to myself
because I don't get more than three and
a half to four hours of sleep so if I
don't look at my physical fitness I'm
gone
ladies and gentlemen do you give time
for yourself do you have time for
yourself your personal time
or is that wheel out of balance is it a
flat tire the Third
will
Tire of the car of life is your
professional life
your personal life needs attention
your family life needs attention
your professional life needs attention
and the fourth is your social life
dear friends
people around you your colleagues
those relationships that matter a lot to
you
those people who would support you in
time of need
because to your spouses to your family
you could speak a little
sometimes certain things are not always
confided with just blood relationships
you need that social side
people to whom you can speak
open up your heart
how often do we just carry this baggage
of stress and load anxiety and worry in
our heads
lugging it all around us baggage
this is social side to our life
a friends
you know I've had those moments where
I've snapped
even as a monk
because I'm a human being
just because I put this Robes of a monk
doesn't mean I've become you know a
Celestial angel
I'm still a human being
when one of those tires is out of Arabic
I haven't slept well if my health is out
of place I'm going to snap out
you know
you carry work pressures at home you
carry home pressures
at work ladies and gentlemen
irritability is a symptom of an out of
balance life
stability
in our responses is a symptom of a life
imbalance
we are irritable we snap we react at the
drop of a hat for trivia
just because we are out of balance
people who have a balanced life
know how to handle pressure
people whose lives are not balanced sink
under pressure
and get so irritable at little things
they just kind of snap off I'm actually
a camera shy person believe it or not
you know when people shoot me and they
just post some clips that's fine with me
but talking to a camera
it's a machine it's just some electronic
machine
the camera doesn't laugh the camera
doesn't cry the camera doesn't have any
interpersonal reciprocations and
dealings and I must tell you
felt very nervous effectively fearful as
well to speak into a camera it was more
fear of failure I would say because you
know when you speak into a camera and if
it's relayed and it's put online how do
people see it otherwise when I'm with
people people have seen me speak
and I decided when the motive is to
serve and contribute we have to face our
fears we have to deal with our fears
face them and rise above them at some
point of time I had to decide to come
and speak
one day I decided that's it I have to
come speak in front of the camera the
first time I did it believe me we will
post that video Once you must see me
speaking there stiff expressionless
motionless stoic nonchalant face you
know and I guess I'm kind of slowly
getting better because in order to deal
with these fears you have to face them
it'll start somewhere it's a beautiful
slide
when followed in life
I guarantee you
life will be different
I guarantee you if this is applied in
life
we can have peaceful nights sleep
here it is
do you have a problem in life
no
then why worry
do you have a problem in life yes can
you do something about it yes then why
worry
do you have a problem in life yes can
you do something about it no then why
worry
isn't it
in the Journey of life as well
the takeoff
which is our birth
is completely beyond our control we
didn't choose our parents we didn't
choose which nation we were born in we
didn't choose which city people born in
we didn't choose our socio-economic
class we were born in we didn't choose
our looks we didn't choose the religion
we were born in our takeoff of the
Journey of life
was completely Beyond us
and the landing
death
even that will be completely Beyond us
I've heard many times people telling me
that they would just love to die
by getting a massive heart attack and
dropping dead no trouble for them no
hospitalization no tubes no needles no
trouble cost to others in one shot go
now no matter how much we might wish
that
it's just beyond us
how we go and how the landing happens is
completely Beyond us
and what about the turbulence the
disturbances the problems during the
Journey of our life
some of them are within our control
which we can solve for many problems and
issues and the turbulence caused is
completely beyond our control because
it's caused by situations which are
Beyond us it's caused by people who are
Beyond us
yes ladies and gentlemen
in this journey of life we take off the
landing and the turbulence
is not in our control
what is in our control however
is the choices we can make
and therefore spirituality
is about learning how to make those
right
choices
when we learn to make those right
choices we learn to live a transformed
happy fulfilled life despite all the
turbulence and problems that are going
on around us
it is said when we are beautiful
it's God's gift to us
when we live our life beautiful
it is our gift to God
therefore being a male is a matter of
birth
being a man
is a matter of age
being a gentleman is a matter of choice
and as a corollary to that
being a female is a matter of birth
being a woman
is a matter of age being a gentle woman
is a matter of choice
let us all
take to spiritual wisdom
learn to make the right choices which
are within our control as our gifts to
God and thus live our lives
as thorough and perfect ladies and
gentlemen I was telling the story the
other day this is my favorite story I
just keep sharing it all the time this
is what really happened you can't
believe this but this happened I came to
London Heathrow once and at London
Heathrow
I came to the immigration officer and
this immigration officer elderly man he
said so what are you here for I said to
give talks he said then are you living
at your what food center I said yeah he
said how long will you stay here for I
said about two weeks uh he said and can
I ask you a personal question I said
please sir he said
are you married
[Music]
I said you are an Indian aren't you
I'm a monk
he said no I was just cross-checking
just in case
and then he said can I ask you another
one please I said yes he said are you
not missing anything in life
he thought he caught me at the wrong
foot
are you not missing anything in life I
said of course I am
he said what
I said problems
you know what
he loved my answer
believe me hand on my heart he stamped
my passport and as I'm walking out of
the gate he put his hand on my head
blessing me said Son remained like this
Sons remained like this you will never
have to go through any issues and your
problems in life God you know what
I mean it's nice to laugh at but as I
walked through the gate I turned to him
and told him look gentlemen I must tell
you something
don't think that me as a monk is free
from problems
[Music]
world as they might say
or anyone who lives in this world full
of rat race and pressures
whether it's you who are a student study
or one of you corporates or business
people who's working
a married man or lady who's kind of
dealing with Family Life
for myself as a monk
we are all subject to our own pressures
we are all subject to our own stresses
we are all subject to our own individual
worries and anxieties
just the flavor is different
a lady asked me after the session in the
Q a session sir you said that you were
an electrical engineer
why did you give up your career as an
electrical engineer
does it matter I didn't give up my
career as an electrical engineer
I upgraded my career from being an
electrical engineer to a lifestyle
engineer and I said to her each of us
based on our particular faculties of
knowledge should be contributing to the
world's solutions to problems
engineering is all about offering
Solutions
all Engineers are offering solutions to
trouble all bodies of knowledge are good
solutions to problem and I thought mine
is one offering Solutions
problems related to Lifestyle problems
happening challenges happen struggles
happen issues happen misunderstandings
happen Health crises happening Financial
crunches happen markets go down and that
happens all of that happens happiness
doesn't happen we have to make it happen
because right things don't happen you
have to make the right things Fitness is
the right thing doesn't happen you have
to make Fitness happen and if you want
to lose any weight losing weight doesn't
happen you have to make it happen not
reacting when you're angry shutting that
Bloody mouth up doesn't happen you have
to make it happen only wrong things
happen automatically right things you
have to make them happen they don't
happen like that I'll tell you what we
all react in our own ways to lose it not
reacting and shutting this up doesn't
happen you have to make it happen saying
oh sorry when somebody hurts you or
forgiving somebody when somebody hurts
you doesn't happen you have to make it
happen but sometimes you find child
prodigies
you know they're like Masters and
singing or dancing or writing or
whatever they do
they keep people you see two-year-old
kids when their hands work go on a piano
Spellbound now don't tell me that he
could learn that and master it at that
age
don't tell me
a two-year-old can't master the alphabet
don't tell me that he mastered it by
learning it
in fact nobody taught it to him
he got it
he got it now when you say he got it
don't call it genetic how does g how do
genes give you a music skill
how
so I know kids young little kids who are
like prodigies in what they do at one
and a half but two
uh it's absolutely phenomenal and then
now where is where is faith and belief
here
it's rational logic that this guy has it
it's not come from learning it's not
come from Reading nobody imparted to him
must come from somewhere How can there
be any effect Without a Cause
and I can't see an immediate cause right
now so there has to be a remote cause
before this right you know what I mean
whether I call it karma whether I call
it whatever but I I can't accept an
effect without a cause it's against my
rational thinking you know so now you if
this gentleman this little boy or little
little girl he or she has this
incredible Talent
we call it the common parlance is he or
she is God gifted absolutely absolutely
God Gifted Man look at sky
not learned look at how they're doing it
so that's that to me is called love
called it Destiny call it karma Call It
Whatever I didn't get I didn't grab it I
got it Matthew McConaughey
when he got the Oscar
he said something phenomenal I loved it
in fact it's written in the book as well
he first of course thanked God thanked
his wife thanked his father thanked his
mom
and he said I want to thank God
[Music]
so I want to thank God because
opportunities are not given by the human
hand I didn't seek a lot and it came to
me
how do I explain it
there's a million other people who are
seeking they don't get it that's right
and I don't seek and I get it what am I
going to explain it by you know you know
what I mean now what that little one
does with that Talent
or what that what this gentleman does or
this lady does with the opportunity that
has come
is my free will or my choice whether to
drive right to drive left or to not
drive right correct but the car
for a lot of people was given correct
now
that Free Will part is where I often
like to quote I say I don't know who
said it but it's a beautiful quote it
says when hard work beats Talent when
talent doesn't work hard
you know so now the talent came to you
when you were two
you don't do nothing with it
has no meaning it has no meaning so you
didn't drive the car you grossly abused
the Fantastic gift the car that you were
given yes correct and then the others
may not get a car like that but they
have their own car
which they now need to identify that's
called self-discovery yes to be able to
identify what's the car you've been
given
what's what's it that you've been gifted
with and everybody has been gifted with
something there are five levels of
people
on level one the lowest level
is a person who only sees bad in others
For Heaven's Sake that God just cannot
see any good anyone here like that I
don't think so we're not so bad that we
just can't see any good some people just
can't see and you know it's like when
you like someone even if the guy does
the biggest crimes
you like him but when you don't like
someone even if he does the good best
thing you don't like him
and if you have that experience if you
just don't like someone even if he has
all the good qualities you just can't
like him
there are some people on that lowest
level
they only focus on the bad they can't
see the good a level higher
are those who see the good and the bad
but conveniently ignore the good and
focus on the bad
how often it happens when we live with
people there's so many good things in
them but conveniently we neglect the
good things and only focus on the bad my
husband digs the nose okay
[Music]
he digs his nose but he also does many
other good things
how come you forgot all of those and
Only God
you saw that
how come you only saw that you know we
conveniently neglect the good and focus
on the man the third category of people
are those who see good and bad
equally and the neutral they're not
concerned good bad they're in their own
world
the fourth category are those who see
the good and bad
they choose to ignore the bad or deal
with the bad
and focus on the good
if you want to like a person you have to
be on level four
if you want to like a person if you're
on level 2 where you're ignoring the
good and focusing on the bad how will it
like that person and how will that
relationship be deep
when you're on level four
where you choose to ignore the man or if
the need be deal with the bad
and focus on the good
and the fifth level is
those who only see good that's God and
spiritually enlightened individuals who
will only see good in others anybody
here who's on level one only seeing bad
can raise your hand nobody okay thank
you anybody is here on level five only
seeing good if you raise your hand I
don't believe you oh sorry madam I do
believe you I'm so I didn't see you
raise your hand I was just joking sorry
I I truly believe you madam I I didn't
see you raise your hand please I just
happened to save thinking nobody is
thank you madam we really appreciate can
we give a loud Round of Applause for her
my God amazing okay now in your close
relationships in your close
relationships how many of you find
yourself many times stuck at level two
level two where you kind of look at the
bad
and forget the good that they have
thank you
in our relationships we need to come to
level
four I'll tell you what
the nature of problems is that it
consumes our mind
am I in a tooth
I don't know if somebody's had their
fingers stuck in the edge of the door
and the door slammed
good Heavens it hurts like hell
and then the pain is just so
all-consuming the mind just focuses so
much on the pain right
I think it's just the nature of problems
that it draws our mind towards them
like the tongue going towards the cumin
sea in my tooth when it was stuck it's
like Gravity the law of gravity we put
this bottle up and put it up here and
drop it it's going to just be pulled
down yeah dragged down by the power of
gravity I think there's a power of
gravity existing within us as well
they're just natural for us to be
dragged down
to our issues our problems
right to everything that's negative
I think being being pulled into
negativity is so normal it's like
gravity
put this portal down and fall stuff you
know how to do anything
but if I were to pull water up from the
ground floor to the eighth floor
I need a mortar correct to work against
gravity and I need conscious hard work I
have to bring it there so it's so
natural for the mind to feel negative
and go towards the problem
but if I have to look at 31 other teeth
I have to make a conscious choice to
take my tongue away right if I have to
pull the water down from the ground
floor to the eighth floor I have to put
a pump to pull it off
it's not easy work it's hard work right
but hard work pays off that's when you
like look at really saying okay this is
fulfilling me now you know that and and
I I definitely don't want to impose this
this principle of gratitude in a
in a unrealistic way on people because
sometimes misery is so intense
absolutely
you know when troubles are smaller
you can still consciously look at the
brighter side of life
you know but sometimes troubles are just
so intense and massive and they seem to
be like mountains
unmoving unshakable
mountains they just stand there for ages
and decades
[Music]
how in such a situation wouldn't it be
so violent
to forcefully impose the principle of
gratitude on a person
whose life is so acutely absorbed and
intense misery right you know I call
that toxic positivity
it's toxic
it's not natural
so what does one do really yeah it just
yeah it's such a situation
when it just so
overwhelmingly painful you know my take
on it is it's hard to look at the
brighter side when this intense pain
there
but at the same time I also feel if we
are consumed by negativity with that
pain and that problem and it's occupying
our mind
we lose the ability to deal with it the
way we are meant to do
correct so if we could seek help if I'm
not able to see it we could seek help of
somebody it could be professional help
personal help friends whoever it could
be he could seek help to be able to
shift our attention to even the tiniest
things
so that that little positivity becomes
the anchor
I want to just offer to you three
essential principles of gratitude
being Mindful and grateful
the first one being
recognizing
all the wonderful things that have been
done to us
believe me you we are in such a such a
rush most of the time we're not even
thoughtful and mindful to recognize the
incredible gifts that have been showered
upon us
how many of you had loving parents
most all of us how many of us feel that
we've been receiving so much affection
from our parents yes how many of you
have loving spouses you might want to or
may not want to raise your hands that is
completely up to you it's your choice
ladies and gentlemen whether you want to
raise your hands for this
how many of you had wonderful teachers
how many of you had some amazing
French
wait how many of you have come in
contact with some wonderful spiritual
personalities
great and how many of us feel that our
life is a collective sum total of the so
many wonderful things that have been
done to us by so many in our lives
show off hands please
all of us isn't it so many of us have
been
recipients and received so much from our
families from our friends from our
teachers from Saints I'll tell you
something to be very honest what the
world needs today
is transformed individuals
we have a lot of affluence we have a lot
of influence
we have a lot of information
we are in an age which is laid Laden
with information you know what we truly
need
is transformed individuals who can
utilize what we have for constructive
causes in the world who can truly bring
light to the world who can truly bring
hope to the world there's enough
information what we would need is
transformation
and what better away
but to have a spiritual culture
to bring that transformational
individuals and in fact I don't want to
say it but I must but spirituality
happens to be one of those major ways to
bring transformation
I see so many people following different
parts of spirituality and change and
transform
to not just be a part of competition but
be a part of contribution along with
competition they're also looking at
contribution
foreign
youngsters young men and ladies are the
ones who can change the shape of planet
Earth who can change the way the world
functions bringing in incredible hope
and light to the world you know when
we're talking about science and
spirituality I I feel that I never felt
there is a divide or a difference right
I feel the purpose is one
when we look at both having the same
purpose which is to unveil the truth
correct science is trying to unveil the
truth and spirituality is wanting to
unveil the truth so how are we different
in our purpose correct the methodologies
may be different like in science I may
use uh
equipment I mean with instruments and
they use telescopes such as measurements
I may use so many different things to be
able to figure out what that truth is
correct and I will yes I will
phenomenally will correct so from
science and from all what I see
[Music]
but I have facts not complete facts yet
which is why it's always evolving we
call it a relative science it's not an
absolute science mental life's periodic
table right the values were changing
right we found out the truth later we
assigned a certain value he said sorry
sir this is not what it is this is the
actual value so it's changing so could I
say that this is it may not be if I get
an instrument which is better than what
I have today I'll probably explore
another layer of that same facet right
now that's where I get the facts great I
need those facts when we talk about
spirituality it is giving the purpose of
those facts so we should be working in
tandem spirituality and science science
moment to work in tandem one looking at
unveiling the truth by giving us factual
data
and one saying giving the philosophical
side saying what is the purpose of this
data correct what is the purpose of this
existence and both are two important
Dimensions to the same truth
you know so I I feel that's an
artificial divide it's an artificial
dividend and it's rigidity on both parts
both sides that we can't come together
to sit and say Hey look
I'll give you an example should a doctor
should a doctor repair a car
that's not a skill set
[Music]
should a car mechanic try and do an open
heart surgery no so if I this is my area
of expertise
let me do that much and not delve into
something further okay let somebody else
with this other area of expertise come
together and let's pull it all together
to unveil the truth together
adding our own Dimension to it the one
thing that I've learned over the years
is that we are also different our lives
are so different our situations are so
different our backgrounds are so
different our upbringing is so different
the Journey of our life up until now for
each one of us is so different compared
to somebody else and therefore it's so
important that we don't judge our own
life all the lives of others by
comparing them with someone else's life
here's an example
if Mr a can Sprint a distance of 10
kilometers in one hour whereas Mr Beaker
was the same distance in one and a half
hour which one of the two would you call
faster and healthier
the answer obviously would be Mr a
now what if I tell you that Mr a had a
prepared track to run on when Mr B
drilled by walking on a Sandy path I
think our answer will not change and we
probably think that Mr B is fitter and
let's say we come to know that actually
Mr a is 75 years old when p is only 20.
here we go our answer changes again and
we now think that the 75 year old Mr a
is healthier guess what Mr aov 60 kg
where is Mr P 125 kg which makes it
really hard for him to run who do you
think did well oh my goodness now we
correct ourselves again as we favor Mr B
the more we get to know about the
strengths and limitations of Mr A and B
respectively our opinions and judgments
about who is better keep changing and
isn't life like that as well guys we
form opinions about others so quickly so
hastily so impulsively so superficially
without knowing much about them or their
situations we end up judging people
labeling people and miss out on
connecting to and encouraging the
immense potential that they may have
the same for all some may not be as
talented as others but make it better
opportunities and thus scale up very
fast whereas others despite being super
talented keep struggling just to make
the ends meet
some may have more resources whereas
others can't find any source to fall
back on
each one has different problems and so
no one solution can work for all just
like one size of clothing doesn't fit
all so do not judge others Journey
without knowing more do not judge your
own life by looking at someone else's or
comparing your situation with someone
else's
are you and they are they your life is
your life and theirs is theirs don't
take inspiration from their journey in a
way that you can enrich yours no always
remember life is the most difficult exam
many people fail because they try to
copy others not realizing that everyone
has a different
I've done three talks in three cities in
India
early late morning like about nine ish
I've spoken in Bangalore in India after
that was overcome to the airport go to
Chennai for another one finish that and
come back to Mumbai and straight from
the airport go to another I've been
three talk in three cities in a way what
do you if I snap well
you're technically right I did
but you're practically wrong ladies and
gentlemen
I don't snap like that
you can interact with me all the time I
don't snap like that
but I'm a human body and a human machine
in your relationships ladies and
gentlemen I make a humble appeal to all
of you and beg of you life is short
it's very short
don't mess up with people
the closest people to you
give time to them
can understand them
they may be you they may have said
something here and there and you may be
technically right okay
look at the Hidden Mango yes your
husband or your wife may not love you
and that's technically right
but there may be a Hidden Mango why find
that out before you Brandon
your son or daughter may not listen to
you and you may be completely
technically right that they don't obey
you but find out the Hidden Mango why
are they doing what they are doing they
are doing that is clear everybody knows
it it doesn't need two pence worth of
Common Sense is it a rocket science to
understand that
is it a rocket science to understand
he's not behaving right any damned fool
can understand it
it needs intelligence and maturity to go
behind the technical rightness and look
for the Practical rightness it looks it
needs maturity and wisdom to start
seeing behind the scene
to see why is this person not loving me
why is this person behaving like that
why is this person not treating me right
and if you do that
believe me handle my heart your love for
whoever you love
will go so deep
and your relationship with whoever you
relate to will be so profound because
it's based on maturity not judgmentalism
how can every morning be the same how
can every afternoon be the same how can
every evening be the same how can every
day be the same
if it is a different day
and therefore they changed the greeting
now
greeting good morning
happy morning
happy morning sir happy morning how are
you doing this morning happy morning
good morning
[Music]
you can say good morning because it's
sometimes there may be nothing good in
that money
nothing good in that day so now the term
is Happy morning
happy morning
because whether the morning is good or
not
you can still choose to be happy right
whether it's good or not it cannot be a
choice
whether the morning is good or not for
you cannot be a choice it's not a choice
for you
when you wake up some virus may enter
into your head and you get up with a
high fever it's not a child you have
whether the morning is good or not is
not in your control whether the
afternoon is good or not it's not in
your control of the evening of control
whether the day is good or not is not in
your control but whether you can be
happy in that moment well you can choose
to be
when people smile it doesn't mean things
are going good
it just means that they've chosen to
smile how many of you breathe
I am sorry for asking that question how
many people breathing for the last
couple of minutes as I started this talk
I'm sure all of you have how many of you
are conscious of your breathing
mindful of your breathing I don't think
so any of us
how many of you use an Apple watch any
of you
and do you know that on an Apple Watch
there's a facility which gives you
giving you reminders after every one
hour time to breathe
[Music]
yeah if you use an Apple Watch you know
that it gives you a reminder after every
one hour time to breathe and focus and
being mindful of your breathing ladies
and gentlemen
none of us in the last one odd hour of
shall I say through the day
have been conscious of our breathing
now imagine when you start breathing and
you just keep breathing in and then and
then and then and then can you live
no
and imagine if you start breathing out
and you breathe out and you breathe out
and you breathe out can you live
no can you imagine how life is fashioned
in such an incredible sophisticated
refined rhythm
the rhythm of breathing
when we talk about life we talk about
we're so unconsciously this taking in
this giving out mistaking in
this giving out if we just keep taking
in we choke up
and if we just keep giving out we choke
up what an incredible balance life has
to teach us
what an incredible Rhythm simply our
breathing has to teach us
that life can't just be a life of takers
where we just keep taking kept taking
just taking or taking nor can life be
just
giving giving giving giving
the rhythm of breathing gives us an
incredible message
[Music]
take in
to give out
have to share grab
to care
that incredible balance that incredible
equation is what makes life amazing
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more rules of success from sad Guru
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there believe
me you're not going to be here forever
I'll bless you with a long life but
you're going to fall Dead one day if
you're beginning to think that what
you're doing is very important you need
to take a holiday you cannot fight